I don't know like are you not jealous because I don't want to share my partner.
Hello
and I have my polyamorous people on the left spotlight and my monogamous and
people on the right spot bite
walk forward if you agree to stay there.
If you disagree with humans are naturally polyamorous,
we would be the ones.
The way I think of myself as polyamorous is even more broad than sexuality.
It's just simply like,
you know,
I can see the beauty in and adore and love qualities of an infinite number of
people.
If I just recognize myself in another person.
Yeah,
we don't just love one kid.
We love multiple children.
We don't just love one friend maybe wanting this loved one job.
We're in la how we probably have 12 jobs.
Most of the three of us here,
people will have a guide in divorced and remarried and it's like,
oh I'm on my fourth marriage.
You know like how does that work out?
Is like that's really starting to our business.
That is Kinda like polyamory over time actually.
It's just a circle.
Non Indian when you could've just been true to yourself and have those multiple
relationships,
whether they had a piece of paper or not.
Yeah,
I understand that a lot of fair marriages fail,
but at the same time,
I feel like a lot of people don't put in the effort that they should.
If people are willing to try and do the best that they can,
then try to be the best for this one person.
It can definitely work.
A lot of people in polyamory wan to use the divorce example as a reason for why
they're polyamorous and they understand,
but at the same time it's,
you can't really know until you try it.
And a lot of people that are monogamous think that polyamory is just all sex.
No,
I've been with the same guy for six years and I've never felt like I needed to
be with someone else and if I did,
I would have just left him.
As bad as that sounds,
I just can't imagine like feeling equally for two people.
He's going to have to be equal though.
It doesn't know you see you like,
I mean for lack of better words like rank your partners like wait,
you have a primary partner in most,
even in polyamorous relationships I'm going to open relationship,
not polyamorous,
which isn't about just sex but it isn't.
I do have a primary partner who I live with and who I spend time with you.
I share bills with a nice share,
a family with and then I have other partners maybe who I shared dinner and
drinks were there.
We have a similar career interest and someone will just love making out with,
so I think that there are,
yes,
there's compartmentalize ways and there are people who do have two equal
partners.
I think that's probably the minority versus the majority.
Just the monogamous relationships.
Nobody's married just the same as what you make it as the boundaries you make.
It's your relationship.
It's not nobody else's relationship.
I got to high five you on that one.
The charge right there.
Okay.
I am in love.
Why did you hesitate before coming?
Because I had to think about how I'm answering that question.
I was thinking about someone outside of myself and it occurred to me that I can
answer this question in a different way and that's been a very big theme in my
life the last few years coming out of a divorce and a monogamous marriage,
20 years of monogamous relationships and um,
and the theme of my life for myself right now is finding love with myself and
being in love with myself.
I feel like throughout my relationships I have found a lot of love for myself.
Like all of the girls that I had dated and my girlfriend now currently like have
all taught me so many things.
I feel like that's one of the main things and the relationship,
like you love someone so much and then you learn from them and they learn from
you and you guys grow together and it's just like a beautiful thing.
My name is Alek Tina,
but I go by Alia and honestly as a person I don't think I would be able to give
someone what they want and what they need in that relationship.
If I had more than one partner.
I have been married for two years and um,
but I've been with my wife for over eight years and she was my only girlfriend.
So it's about as monogamous as against.
Yeah.
But very much still in love.
Um,
yeah.
I love her more every day.
In a weird way.
My relationship,
it allowed me to love myself more when I was with someone who totally accepted
all parts of me who was like,
be that it's a beautiful,
it's sexy.
It allowed me to love myself more.
And that's,
I think the beauty of open for me is it,
it's complete acceptance for me and my decisions.
There is no,
well you can't do this or well,
your urges are bad or this is bad about you.
It's be who you want to be.
Let's talk about it.
Okay.
I actually read about,
uh,
polyamory like when I was in my early twenties I remember being mount like,
this sounds so like it was read something about,
it was resonating with me.
Like I just didn't realize it was that much of an option.
I didn't see much of a model in society.
I thought,
well,
even if I want that,
how would I find someone else who's into the same things I am?
And in the last couple of years I've been really just saying like,
I need to explore this.
And you define community.
I'm not someone who says I don't believe in monogamy.
As a matter of fact,
having a chance to really explore both sides has given me an understanding,
appreciation for both.
And also understanding the limitations of both.
There is a good reason why most people are monogamous.
I don't know.
Like are you not jealous?
Because I feel like that's a main reason why I wouldn't be able to do that as,
I don't know,
want to share my partner at all.
Yeah.
I don't share.
It's like I am with you and you're with me
and you know,
we're together and we're growing and the few don't want me anymore and you want
to go explore.
Are there things?
Go and explore them,
but on your own,
you know,
I think that's crazy.
Um,
just because in every other area in our life,
you have to control jealousy.
Jealousy is not a attribute to be proud of to say I'm a jealous person.
Like if you are at work,
you can't be a jealous person.
Function well at the office you can't function well in your family or with your
friends has a jealous person.
And so why in this one area of your life do you say,
this is where I get to be the person that I can't be anywhere else.
The idea of jealousy of I'm afraid because I've put so much,
it's kind of like the slot machine approach.
I've sat in this machine,
I put in so many quarters I want to get,
reap the benefits,
but if this is someone that you love,
does,
does that extend to that?
If he said,
this is someone that I think might be a better fit,
if my husband said,
I found a different person that I want to be with and she's fulfilling a need
that you don't or can't,
then I'd be like,
okay,
go be happy with her.
Like,
yeah,
it's not natural for me to be like,
okay,
let's the three of us work this out
and to me that jealousy is just rooted in the fact that you're completely
intimate,
you've made a commitment to each other and this is the person that is basically
like your second half.
Having that jealousy for your significant other is beautiful and in a way
I think monogamy is a practical choice because it's safer sexually.
One,
two,
it's probably a lot simpler and it's,
it's prepackaged.
I mean it's like here's a set of rules that has been created for you hundreds of
years ago.
Here's what love looks like and if that feels comfortable for you,
it's easy.
What?
Monogamy is an easy,
you know,
monogamy is hard.
Like being with someone and being with them for 10 15,
50 years is very hard.
You have to find ways to love your partner for truly who they are,
all the good and all the bad and you don't have someone else to turn to when you
want something new.
You have to find that in your relationship.
You have to find a way to spice things up.
You have to find the way of making conversation where you know everything about
each other.
Why don't we have one friend?
Why not just one friend?
Why do you need multiple friends at all?
I mean most of us probably have 10 friends,
20 friends,
5,000 Facebook friends.
Why?
Why not just have one Facebook friend?
Because you don't build such a strong connection with a friend.
You build a strong connection with a partner because the partner gets to know
everything.
And every single thing will be,
because there's different levels of friendship.
But like when you're in a relationship with someone,
you explore so many more things in so many different facets of your day.
Because at some point you will move in together and you know,
you'll see what everyone does like day to night and you'll get to know
everything about them.
You don't really get that with one friend.
I do have like a best friend.
Yeah.
But the reason he's
my best friend is cause he's different than every other friend I have.
And if I have something really,
really serious,
really,
really important,
I'm going to him first.
What,
you still have other friends?
Sure.
And I,
and I equate that to uh,
what she was saying earlier about having a primary partner.
For example,
you know,
you could have a primary partner that you have intimacy that you live with,
do you have sex with and you may have like,
let's,
let's equate that to me with your best friend.
And then there could be someone else that you hang out and you play baseball
with,
you do other activities with,
you know,
and I could have another person,
we make music together and we do things and yeah.
When did we have sex?
Once in a while too.
It's interesting that,
you know,
I think from the traditional model,
the fact that I would have any physical connection with this other person is
what distinguishes it as an issue.
If my partner wanted me to,
I would consider going to the other side.
Oh hell yeah.
Um,
I was monogamous for a lot of my life and that was for the reasons that were
felt authentic to me at the time.
And I've been nonmonogamous for some time now,
which has been authentic for me for this time.
And I think that for me the important thing is always keeping an open mind and
realizing that life is constantly evolving.
I think one of the things I disliked about monogamy or when I was in a
monogamous relationship is all of the you need to,
or you should or that we have a prearranged agreement of what loving charter
means.
And if you don't obey that it's over.
And I wanted to give my partner a true open experience.
And so if I'm going to say to you,
it can't be monogamous,
well how is it really open?
Because there is a condition on there of like,
well this is the only way this is going to work.
So it's always open to me means open for discussion.
Can I jump in?
And what you said about like loving and you know,
fully accepting someone.
I just know that I as a person wouldn't be able to be in the polyamorous
relationship and keep myself happy.
So if my partner were to suggest,
I would say,
you know,
I don't think I'm capable of doing that and I would still love them.
I would support them.
I would want to be friends with them.
I would want them to be as happy as they can be,
even if it doesn't involve me in their life.
I think what the strength that non-monogamy has over monogamy is that we're
saying,
who are you?
Who am I?
Let's figure out something that makes sense for us versus this is what I was
told love is let's try and do that thing.
I don't feel like I live that way
because someone told me to.
I just don't have the want to add other people.
Well,
until you don't have that desire,
it's authentic to you.
Yeah,
and I think that so many people on this earth have the desire and they think
they don't have the option.
My name is jasmine.
I actually married my very first boyfriend.
We just steal loped and we got married about two years ago and we've been
together ever since.
A good sex life is necessary for a good relationship.
Yeah.
If sucks dies from the relationship and your love and lust for each other kind
of dies,
um,
then you might be better off as friends and partners as friends.
Sex is so much more than just physical that it makes a big impact in how I feel
in my relationship.
If I don't have sex,
I'm going to feel like disconnected.
Like there's something off in a relationship.
Ultimately.
You mean I talk about sex,
we're living,
it's a big part of my life.
It's a big part of my reset if I'm not have sex with you and do it myself.
Like I really enjoy it.
Orgasm has ridiculous amounts of health benefits and it just feels great.
So I love the physicality of it.
But I also think that every person should like really define what are the top
five things you have to have in a relationship.
And for a lot of people,
sex doesn't hit that top five.
And if it doesn't,
that's okay.
You can still make a relationship work and that's sex being a priority.
But if you're someone like myself,
you can't,
I'm in the same boat with you.
Like I've always been a very like sexually driven person.
I'm an explorative person.
Um,
and,
and all pretty much all the monogamous relationships I was in,
I never found someone that,
let's say matched my kink.
So having a partner that's like really on the same page with me as explorative
and open as I am is really like fruity much at like the top one or two things
that I would say in a relationship for me.
Sexist in everything in life,
Huh?
If the sexual tension is,
they're awesome.
But what happens after the section,
the sexual tensions is gone.
Like was that it was just sex,
the sexual tension dies out.
It is kind of a can,
but that's the whole point of like where people have to rekindle it and they
have to try new things and they have to see what works to make the spark come up
again.
Because after he spent so much time with someone and you know them so well it
can get lost.
But it's a continuous effort of trying to make your sex life the best it can be.
Even in a non monogamous relationship,
you still have to do that.
Like I don't think it's healthy to like just go run out and look for things.
Other things,
just because my primary relationship is like not working.
Like it's still neat.
You know,
that that relationship still needs work.
Every relationship needs work
well.
I think,
uh,
like sex is important.
I mean,
I can just think of all the things that sometimes like sex can just cure and
relationship.
Um,
and I don't know what it's like to,
you know,
have a terrible sex life.
So I guess take this with a grant.
But you know,
I don't think,
I think
about the amount of time you spend with your,
your partner,
right?
Compare that to the amount of time you have sex with them.
I think a lot,
a lot more happens besides sex and a relationship is,
I mean it's like how much fun you have.
Like the intimacy,
you shared conversations,
everything.
Right.
You know,
making sex,
not just about sex,
it's about connecting to so someone,
right.
So I think it would feel like it's a space,
it's a really amazing space to like to explore that connection in the closest
physical way you possibly can.
I feel like if sex was your first like priority,
you wouldn't really be in relationships.
You would be finding sexual partners that fit you,
but you wouldn't really care about anything else.
I feel like sex plays a big role,
but also we're,
you know,
we're puzzles,
like we have so many pieces and we have so many needs and so many things that we
want to fulfill,
but sex I think is pretty important for most people.
I've been attracted to other people while in a relationship.
Shit.
Oh,
well,
good for you.
Oh,
okay.
I feel like I found people pretty nothing to a point where I would even consider
acting on it.
I don't think you can only be attracted to one person.
I feel like that's really unrealistic.
I think it's crazy thing to deny that because I mean I think of every species
exist in says survival and procreation.
So to think that you to shut off that entire part of yourself,
not you just,
I think action is one thing because people have successfully done that.
But in terms of feeling or seeing some muscles attractive,
that's crazy.
Apparently there is one person that can say this conversation the question a
different way.
I just,
I can't wrap my head around.
It's totally possible that we can all be wired a little bit differently.
Like we're all on a different point in the scale and I think our life experience
also shapes us to a degree as to where on that scale we are.
Tell us,
tell us.
No.
So I know I'm going to sound crazy and I know it's like,
it's something that I always have disagreements with with my friends and um,
I think it is a little bit of what you said,
you know,
being wired differently.
Um,
in the beginning when I first started dating my wife,
that was Giddy,
Giddy,
like in,
in love that like there was just this giant bubble around a relationship.
Uh,
but then as we,
as we matured and our relationship,
we got married,
what,
what I felt uncomfortable with is looking at other women.
Like it actually made me feel uncomfortable.
So the same way that I train myself to like,
if you want to call it suppress or whatever,
uh,
other,
other feelings and impulses I have,
I do the same here.
So whenever I see a girl like,
yeah,
I'm going to walk down the street and I'll turn my head or whatever and there'll
be a girl wearing almost nothing or whatever.
My,
what I've like built in is literally an instinct to just look away and not to
think any further.
Uh,
what I think what's weird to me is like the conversations I'll have with other
people where they'll,
they'll look at,
um,
someone of the opposite sex,
find them attractive and keep going.
And like mentally they're having sex with like all these weird things.
And that's like,
I'm really uncomfortable for me.
You're not saying like,
oh,
I was born only thinking this one person is attractive.
Right.
You're saying you train yourself to be that way?
Pretty much.
Okay.
That makes a lot more sense to me.
Yeah.
I would feel incomplete without my partner
really.
Honestly,
if I ever never met my partner,
I wouldn't be that person.
I am today in the past year of dating my girlfriend,
I have become so different and I've learned so many things and they have started
taking care of myself so much more than that was a year before I met her and
they feel like that has so much to do with her and how she helped me navigate
this.
I had a really unsafe home life and me and my husband got to know each other in
the sixth grades were 12 I moved out when I was 18 me and him like we had
nothing.
We somehow made her way over to La.
Like I honestly don't think I'd be here.
Like if the wasn't for him.
Disagree,
not again.
Oh Man.
I was married for some time.
So my whole journey,
the last two and a half years has been to feel complete by myself.
And um,
there are times like I really do desire partnership.
I do desire a primary partnership,
but I really think it's so important to,
to be okay just being as I am.
When the words incomplete,
I'm like,
no,
I don't connect with that.
I connect with,
I'd feel sad and feel hurt.
Um,
I would feel disadvantaged maybe even,
but I'm still going to be me and I totally understand that we're coming from
different places and how we developed our relationship.
My idea of a relationship is one plus one equals three one complete person plus
one complete person equals a completely separate third is going to do this one
but completely separate third relationship.
And this would be incomplete if of course if we laughed,
but the ones would still stand still and be strong.
All right guys,
thank you so much.
Hey guys,
my name's Dan.
Thank you so much for watching middle ground.
We love having these kinds of discussions and we love to have you guys chime in
on what you guys thought about this episode and what you would like us to do in
future episodes.
So if you'd like us,
subscribe here and can watch more stuff here.
Thank you.